IGNATIUS: Ladies and gentlemen, if you could
finish eating this delicious lunch that the
Council has provided.
I'm David Ignatius, a columnist for The Washington
Post.
It's my pleasure to introduce Senator Chris
Coons, who's going to offer an assessment
of the Iran deal one year later.
It's amazing to me, when I think back a year
ago we talked of almost nothing other than
the Iran nuclear, this is a rare moment when
we all get together and think about how it's
going.
Senator Coons, as I think everyone here understands,
junior senator from Delaware, but someone
who paid special attention to the issues in
this negotiation, followed very closely, was
skeptical.
So when he announced his decision to support
the agreement, that really was the decisive
moment.
He and Senator Casey together brought the
vote total to what the president needed.
I'm just going to read a quote from a Washington
Post story the day we were reporting, September
1 last year, Senator Coons decision.
"Disclosed in an exclusive interview with
The Washington Post, delivered a powerful
blow to opponents of the plan because the
Delaware Democrat had previously voiced some
of the deepest skepticism about the controversial
deal."
So I really do think that was a key moment
a year ago.
I'm especially interested to hear how Senator
Coons evaluates things a year later.
So, Senator.
(Applause.)
COONS: Well, thank you, David.
Thank you both for the kind introduction and
for your willingness to moderate today's conversation.
And I'd like to also thank the Council on
Foreign Relations for hosting this discussion
of the Iran nuclear agreement one year on.
Today, as we approach the one-year anniversary
of the announcement of the Joint Comprehensive
Plan of Action, or the JCPOA, I will evaluation
whether this deal has succeeded so far, and
explain what I've done to honor my commitment
to aggressively oversee its implementation
and its enforcement.
Last year, as David just mentioned, after
closely scrutinizing the terms of the deal,
I concluded that it represented the least-bad
option for achieving one of America's most
important-(audio break)-from Iran from developing
or obtaining a nuclear weapon.
Since implementation day of this agreement
in January, we have seen real and meaningful
progress toward that goal.
As I suspect everyone in this room knows,
but is important to repeat, Iran has shipped
12 tons of enriched uranium-virtually its
entire stockpile-out of the country.
The Iranian regime has reduced by two thirds
the number of its functioning uranium enrichment
centrifuges.
And it has permanently reengineered the Arak
Heavy Water Reactor by filling its core with
concrete.
These three steps in combination cut off Iran's
most likely short-term pathways to a nuclear
weapon with either uranium or plutonium.
Iran has also give the International Atomic
Energy Agency, or the IAEA, the world's nuclear
watchdog, unprecedented 24/7 access to monitor
all of its declared nuclear facilities.
That access covers Iran's entire nuclear supply
chain, from Iranian mines and mills to centrifuge
production and enrichment facilities-every
known nuclear site in Iran.
These steps have, for now, frozen Iran's ability
to develop a nuclear weapon.
And as a result of Iran's initial compliance
with the agreement, the time for it to break
out, to assemble enough fissile material for
one nuclear weapon has extended significantly
from just two or three months to now more
than a year.
So measured by whether the agreement has prevented
Iran from developing or obtaining a nuclear
weapon, this deal has, so far, been successful.
I also, though, have long suspected Iran that
would seek to push the boundaries of the deal
in ways both minor or major, to test how the
United States and our allies would respond.
Earlier this week, I had an in-person meeting
with Ambassador Steve Mull, the Obama administration's
lead coordinator for Iran nuclear implementation.
And I heard what I hoped for, and what I expected,
that the Departments of State, Treasury, Energy,
and our intelligence community are working
closely together to aggressively monitor and
enforce the JCPOA.
American officials also are communicating
regularly and closely with their Iranian counterparts,
with the European Union, and the other key
parties to the deal.
And as I anticipated, there have been a handful
of occasions in the past year in which the
United States has had to mobilize our P5+1
partners to hold Iran closely to the parameters
of the JCPOA.
Here's a public example.
When Iran's heavy water stockpile in February
briefly reached 130.9 metric tons, exceeding
the JCPOA limit of 130 metric tons, the IAEA
quickly observed this anomaly, reported it
to the partner countries, we took action,
and Iran addressed it.
There are several other incidents I can't
describe in public, but in each case the United
States rallied our international partners
to promptly address a discrepancy or disagreement
and successfully enforce this direct interpretation
of the deal.
In the years to come-in the many years to
come-we have to focus on continuing aggressive
enforcement, and congressional oversight will
remain critical.
But we also have to continue to push back
on Iran's destabilizing and provocative actions
outside the four corners, the parameters of
the nuclear agreement.
From its repeated calls for the destruction
of Israel, to its support for terrorism in
Syria and Iraq and Yemen, to its ongoing illegal
ballistic missile tests, and its human rights
violations, Iran is not a responsible state
seeking to rejoin the international community.
These actions underscore an important point
about the deal: The JCPOA was, is, and will
mostly likely remain a transactional, not
a transformational, agreement.
This deal seeks to prevent Iran from developing
a nuclear bomb, not to bring Iran into the
community of nations.
Only a genuine change in direction by the
Iranian regime can do that.
Rather, though, than walking away from the
deal, in my view the United States must remain
engaged, and to lead the international community's
enforcement of the agreement.
As I tell my Senate colleagues regularly,
whether you opposed or supported the JCPOA
last year, we have a shared interest in working
together this year and in the future to make
sure this deal succeeds.
With that said, let me briefly review broadly
where we are today, nearly a year into the
deal.
Two things really haven't changed at all.
First, Iran remains untrustworthy.
Since its 1979 revolution, Iran has pursued
interests and advocated values that are completely
opposed to those of the West.
And its approach to regional crises has not
changed.
Second, Iran continues to exploit weak states
and power vacuums.
And we need to disrupt Iran's destabilizing
activities in the Middle East and to support
our regional partners, most importantly by
promptly concluding a strengthened 10-year
memorandum of understanding on defense priorities
with Israel.
But two additional points I think are worth
emphasizing.
Broadly, the last year has shown that international
agreement and multilateral diplomacy can be
effective, even with rogue states like Iran.
There is value in talking with our enemies.
Second, we're today engaged in a public disagreement
with Iran about whether it is, in fact, seeing
the benefits of the deal.
When Valiollah Seif, the governor of Iran's
Central Bank, spoke here at the Council on
Foreign Relations earlier this year in April,
he argued that the United States and our European
allies had not honored our JCPOA obligations,
because Iran hasn't been able to access the
global financial system, and hasn't realized
the economic benefits they foresaw from this
deal.
But here's how I see it.
The United States has upheld our end of the
bargain.
We have not prevented Iran from receiving
economic benefits associated with the deal.
In fact, their recent activity, significant
increases in oil exports, billions of dollars
in recent deals, and projected economic growth
of 3 to 5 percent casts real doubt on Iran's
claims.
In my view, Iran alone is responsible for
making its market an attractive and safe place
in which to do business.
And for many corporations and individuals,
Iran is neither attractive, nor safe.
And I am concerned that by entertaining Iranian
complaints of inadequate sanctions relief
we risk giving these claims legitimacy.
If Iran is unhappy with the level of economic
benefits its received since the JCPOA, it
has only itself and its own actions to blame.
Today, as we look beyond year one of the JCPOA
and look ahead to five, 10, or 15 years from
now, one thing is clear: If this agreement
is to succeed long term, engaged congressional
oversight remains essential.
This oversight falls into two categories,
starting with congressional pushback on Iran's
bad behavior outside the deal's parameters.
That's why I've continued to be outspoken
on the floor of the Senate in calling for
stronger efforts to interdict Iranian arms
shipments to the Houthi rebels in Yemen, and
in celebrating those interdictions that have
occurred.
I've also asked foreign leaders, including
those from Israel, Saudi Arabia, Qatar, India,
and Russian, about how to strengthen our efforts
together to counter Iranian aggression.
And I've urged Congress to provide this administration
with unilateral authority to address Iran's
ongoing ballistic missile tests, given the
inertia in the U.N. Security Council.
I've called on the administration as well
to levy additional sanctions against IRGC-affiliated
entities, like Mahan Aar, which Treasury has
done.
And I've worked to secure increased funding
for Treasury's Office of Terrorism and Financial
Intelligence, which enforces these sanctions.
But Congress also has to remain engaged in
overseeing the enforcement of the nuclear
deal itself.
In January, I joined a congressional delegation
in visiting IAEA headquarters in Vienna, where
we met with Director General Amano.
The JCPOA allows hundreds of nuclear inspectors
to oversee Iran's nuclear program through
both remote online enrichment monitoring and
intrusive in-person inspections.
These inspectors, trained in America's unique
national labs, are funded by the United States
Congress, and utilize cutting-edge technology,
largely developed by our scientists.
Because we are asking the IAEA to engage in
an unprecedented level of oversight, Director
General Amano has recently publicly raised
concerns that his agency is stretched thin
as it works to implement this deal.
That's why Congress must do our part to ensure
the IAEA has reliable, long-term resources.
This IAEA responsibility has taken on an even
greater importance this week, given recent
news that that agency has detected signs of
North Korean plutonium reprocessing.
The IAEA responsibilities remain global and
important, and need to be effectively sustained.
I've also repeatedly called on Congress to
take full advantage of the IAEA's unprecedented
access to Iran's nuclear program, by increasing
our voluntary contribution to the agency,
which would encourage our international partners
to do so as well.
In addition, I've pressed for the confirmation
of Laura Holgate as U.S. ambassador to the
U.N. offices in Vienna, which includes the
IAEA.
And I've called for the renewal of the Iran
Sanctions Act, so that we have a viable mechanism
to snap back sanctions in Iran violations
the JCPOA.
I intend to uphold my commitment to oversee
strict enforcement of this deal, regardless
of who is elected president this fall.
As our moderator this afternoon recently wrote
in a column: The Iran nuclear agreement deserves
far more attention in this presidential campaign.
And I couldn't agree more.
If we abandon the JCPOA, we don't end up with
a better agreement, nor do we end up with
no agreement.
Instead, our partners around the world will
most likely develop a new strategy to deal
with Iran without American leadership or input.
If we abandon this agreement, we signal that
we're giving up on diplomacy.
We could lose valuable intelligence.
We would forego the support of our allies.
And we would close vital communications channels
to senior Iranian leaders that have helped
to restrain Iran's nuclear program.
Frankly, I think that's exactly what the most
conservative elements in Iran's regime want.
But let me be clear about that.
We can, and we should, distinguish between
the Iranian regime and the Iranian people.
The people of Iran continue to turn out at
the polls to vote, even in elections that
are not truly free nor fair.
They have repeatedly demonstrated in the streets
for democracy and engagement, risking their
lives to do so.
The Iranian people deserve our support in
their struggle for human rights and democracy,
especially during this sacred month of Ramadan,
as Muslims around the world reflect on their
hopes for peace.
But the Iranian regime deserves condemnation
for a decades-long pattern of human rights
abuses, support for terrorism, and other bad
behavior.
The government of Iran, the Iranian regime,
remains a dangerous revolutionary government,
and it will continue to present a potential
nuclear threat for decades to come.
Preventing Iran from obtaining a nuclear weapon
will require steady leadership, an understanding
of the complexities of international diplomacy,
and constant scrutiny of Iran's behavior.
These tasks must be the responsibility not
just of this president this year, but a top
priority for the next president, the intelligence
community, and members of Congress for many
years to come.
That's why I intend to stay actively engaged
in monitoring enforcement of the deal, in
advocating for a strong foreign policy that
supports our allies in the Middle East and
promotes American interests and values around
the world.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
IGNATIUS: Senator, thank you for that.
It was excellent and raised all of the basic
issues.
I just want to dig on some of them.
You can't, in our business, let a news cycle
pass without talking about Donald Trump, as
we all know.
(Laughter.)
So I'm going to begin by just asking you about
what the presumptive Republican nominee has
said about the Iran nuclear deal.
The most frequent comment has been it's a
bad deal and I would have negotiated a better
deal.
He implied in some comments that he would
seek to reopen the negotiation and get that
better deal that he thinks was possible.
In other comments he's implied, but I don't
want to push this too hard but certainly I
came away with the sense, that he might repudiate
the deal.
It was badly negotiated in his judgement.
So I want to ask you directly, what would
be the consequence of either seeking to reopen
the negotiations if the next president concluded
it was a bad deal, or in some way repudiating
the deal?
What would happen if that were done?
COONS: Well, I think without the strong and
united support of our partners in the deal,
seeking to reopen it and renegotiate it is
a fool's errand, and would simply lead to
a mess, to a hash, to an apprehension on the
part of our key allies that we were withdrawing.
It would lead to more aggressive actions by
the Iranians.
I suspect it would lead them to take stronger
steps that indicated a willingness to return
to more active nuclear enrichment and more
active nuclear research.
Or, it might very well lead to a greater distance
between the United States and our core European
allies.
It depends on what else the Donald sought
to renegotiate, given his alarming and irresponsible
statements about NATO, about the nuclear umbrella
for South Korea and Japan, about a whole range
of other topics in foreign policy.
My concern is that it wouldn't be just this
issue on the table, and if all those different
things were afoot at the same time.
One of the core principles of American leadership
in foreign policy, which is to be predictable-particularly
in your commitment to certain alliances and
certain treaties and certain obligations-would
be overthrown.
And a lot of our vital allies would be puzzled
and concerned, and particularly with regard
to Iran, I think likely to renegotiate the
deal around us for their economic and security
benefit, and to rely far lesson American involvement.
As I tried to reference in my remarks, we
are absolutely essential to the successful
implementation of this deal.
America's national labs, America's contributions
to the IAEA, the engagement of our intelligence
community, our role in leading the Atlantic
community I think are all essential to this
deal being successfully implemented.
I think an effort at renegotiating it, even
a bluster, half-hearted attempt, would be
unconstructive.
IGNATIUS: That's very direct and helpful.
I want to pursue one intriguing thing you
said in your opening comments, where you made
reference to certain discrepancies that have
arisen.
You said you couldn't discuss the details
of several of them.
You know, we hear rumors about this, but obviously
we don't have access to the information that
you do.
I want to ask you, not for the details that
you can't share, but for your analytical judgement
about what they tell us.
In these discrepancies, do the Iranians seem
to be pushing at the limits?
Are there genuine differences in reading the
language?
Are they accidental?
What's going on in the cases that have arisen
that you have been able to look at?
COONS: Well, a good friend of mine, who had
long business dealings with Iranians in the
'40s, '50s, and '60s, told me a story before
the deal entered into effect.
And it's a long story, but the punchline was,
after several years of painful, detailed negotiations
at the signing day where they entered into
a new business arrangement, his new Iranian
partner said: All right, now the negotiations
begin.
I think they have a long demonstrated history
of actively and aggressively litigating the
boundaries of almost every arrangement they've
been involved in.
Part of that is cultural.
Part of that is the real gulf between our
values and priorities and our strategic interest
and theirs.
I think there is an open question whether
the excursions and challenges there have been
are the result of internal miscommunication,
whether they are intentional testing of the
West's resolve.
But I think we are safest presuming the latter.
And I think we are safest demonstrating a
robust and sustained and close engagement,
making sure that we are not over-litigating
in response, but promptly and appropriately
and thoroughly responding right up until the
moment we get an action.
One of the lessons we've learned this year
is that the Iranians respond to pressure.
I think that was one of the lessons of the
international sanctions campaign that brought
them to the table.
I think that's one of the lessons of repeated
efforts to identify and call out specific
moments when they are outside the well-known
boundaries of the JCPOA, even by a tiny amount,
even by a footfall.
And I think we see a division within the Iranian
government and regime as to what their long-term
prospects really are, whether they're going
to get significant economic benefit or whether
they should, frankly, give up on that and
turn inward and turn more to active-return
to more active confrontation with the West,
in part through a nuclear program.
IGNATIUS: Let me ask you to focus on that
last issue, of what benefits Iran gets as
a result of the agreement.
It's clear from comments that there is a genuine
sense that the benefits we expected, the opening
in terms of financial markets, opportunities,
just haven't arrived.
You gave a good account of why that's not
our fault in our opening comments, but even
so in terms of the durability of this agreement,
an agreement that people-officials and the
public in the effected country-don't feel
benefits them end up weaken the agreement.
Secretary Lew at Treasury noted that sanctions
lose their force if the removal of sanctions
doesn't bring benefits.
I thought it was a powerful comment that he
made a few months ago.
So if you could address this.
Not to argue the case for Iran, but isn't
it a fact that if they don't get benefits
from having made this deal, support for it
and its integrity, its vitality will diminish?
COONS: Well, first, they are getting real
and concrete economic benefits out of this
deal.
They are shipping and selling their oil on
world markets at a level unseen in recent
years.
And they will eventually get all the economic
benefit that comes from being able to sell
their oil on global markets.
I'll remind you, the price of a barrel of
oil has been cut more than half since they
entered into the negotiations about this deal.
And that's just one way in which their expectations
about how much benefit they would receive
and how quickly have fallen far short of their
expectations.
So their economy is growing again.
They are receiving access to global oil markets.
They are signing lots of big agreements with
international firms.
But they are also, as I pointed out in detail,
continuing to take actions that would make
any rational corporation, individual, and
global banking entity question whether this
was a good economy in which to invest.
Lots of economic players in the region moved
on during the years when sanctions really
cut off the Iranian market.
And here are plenty of other places of opportunity
that are less risky.
And their economy remains opaque.
The IRGC, the Revolutionary Guard Corps, has
a significant role throughout the economy.
And it's important to remember the Iran is
not monolithic.
The IRGC has been one of the biggest beneficiaries
of sanctions.
And so for sanctions and their impact, the
sort of stasis it's imposed on their economy
to unwind, a lot of the economic position
of the IRGC is at risk.
So in order for them to completely open up
their market and be transparent so that Western
entities can assess the risk they're taking
in doing transactions, the IRGC's role has
to change.
It is a corrupt, opaque, militarily controlled
economy.
And if I were sitting in a board room trying
to predict which country we ought to next
try and move into, this wouldn't be on my
top ten.
But that's not a result of American intransigence
or a refusal by the West to grant them access
to the benefits of the deal.
IGNATIUS: President Obama, certainly the last
year of the Iran nuclear debate, I think tried
to lowball expectations about the transforming
power.
As you said in your remarks, it was transactional
not transformative.
Even so, I think anybody who looks at Iran
has an idea that this might be a process of
gradual political change, in which more moderate
forces- a Zarif, Rouhani who supported the
deal, were empowered.
Over time, you had movement to a different
leadership.
Some people see the elections for the Iranian
parliament as reinforcing that idea.
So I want to ask you, without-I'm not asking
for the starry-eyed, gee-whiz, but what do
you think of the prospects for gradual evolution
of Iran as it rejoins the global economy?
Are we going to see a different country, in
your judgement, over the next five to 10 years?
COONS: Over the next five years, I wouldn't
expect that.
Over the next 10 to 20, I think it is possible.
Part of what I tried to convey was a respect
for the depth, complexity, sophistication
of the Persian people, of the culture of Iran.
They are an incredibly educated, sophisticated
people, with a lot of resources and a lot
of capabilities.
But the orientation, the ideology of the current
regime in any-in any reasonable prediction
of how they're likely to behave in the next
couple of years, given the region, given their
current engagements, given their actions in
Iraq, and Syria, Yemen, and elsewhere, I think
only suggests a hardening of the position
of the regime in the short term.
Given the election in the Majlis, given some
of the demographic dynamics, given the underlying
culture, I think it's entirely possible.
And we should remain hopeful that there are
prospects for democratization, for opening
to the West.
But there's several critical timelines at
work here.
The strictures of the JCPOA become less tight
in seven to 10 years.
That is exactly the timeline on which I am
most concerned that American leadership will
drift, that our focus, the priority attention
to this will begin to wander off.
And that's the moment at which there will
be a greater temptation on the part of the
Iranian regime if it is, at that point, undergoing
some challenge or some transition domestically
to return to a nuclear program as a way of
strengthening its nationalist credentials
and strengthening its regional security profile.
That's exactly when I think we will be at
the moment of greatest risk.
So it's my hope that our actions over the
next five years will convince the Iranian
regime that a return to a nuclear program
is profoundly foolish, that further integration
into the regional economy and the global economy
is in their best interest.
And they can only accomplish that by moderating
their behavior.
IGNATIUS: So I see the warning, insistence
that they abide by the terms of the agreement.
But I'm still curious about what you think
the United States should do, if anything,
to encourage a gradual process of political
and cultural change in Iran over the time
period of this agreement.
COONS: I think we should be open to and actively
encouraging progress in terms of cultural
exchanges and engagement with the outside
world, and remain hopeful about the possibility
of political change.
But that's got to rest on a bedrock of distrust
and a clear-eyed assessment of their current
actions.
Their support for the Houthis, the Hezbollah,
for Hamas, their actions in Iraq and Syria
strongly suggest a country that is not ready
to rejoin the international community.
They've got problems in accessing the world
economy, in part, because they arbitrarily
arrest and detain Iranian-American businessmen
who have gone to Iran to try and seek economic
opportunities.
They are ratcheting up the number of youth
that they're executing, the number of journalists
that they're imprisoning.
Their human rights-recent human rights behavior
is atrocious.
Now, to launch ballistic missiles that at
least notionally say on the side of them,
you know, death to Israel, and then express
surprise that the Western world doesn't think
you're really ready to be part of the global
community just belies credibility.
So I think we should remain clear-eyed and
active and engaged in pushing back on their
bad behavior.
And I think that's the best path, frankly,
towards keeping open the hope or the possibility
of some reconciliation regionally.
IGNATIUS: Let me ask a final question from
up here, and then we're going to turn to the
audience.
So please be thinking of your questions for
Senator Coons.
I'd like to ask you to think with us about
Iran's regional behavior.
It was often said by commentators that the
issue wasn't so much the agreement, which
was pretty solid, but Iran's bad behavior,
Iran's destabilizing behavior in the region,
which the nuclear agreement wouldn't address.
As an observer, I would make the following
contrarian observation, that today compared
to a year ago Iran seems, to me, to be a little
bit on its back foot in the region.
The Yemen War, which looked to everyone like
a disaster from the standpoint of the Saudis
and others, seems to be now meandering towards
a diplomatic resolution.
There are talks going on in Kuwait between
Houthis and others.
And there are other quiet talks that are taking
place elsewhere, sponsored, I gather, by the
United States that are also showing some real
prospects of success.
A senior Saudi said to me recently: Iran has
turned out to be a paper tiger in Yemen.
That's one.
Second, Iran's having a lot of trouble in
Iraq.
I mean, Iran has having as much trouble being
a hegemon as we did.
The Shia coalition in Iraq is just fractured.
The Dawa Party's split in two.
And Iran doesn't quite seem to know what to
do about it.
Syria, Iran continues to be trying to help
Bashar al-Assad gain ground, but from what
we read the Iranians are pretty nervous about
taking casualties in that fight.
They don't like it.
And the ayatollah has, from what we hear,
on several occasions tried to reduce his exposure,
make sure there are fewer coffins coming back
to Tehran, not more.
So taking those three areas, and I do mean
to ask this as a contrarian question, is it
possible that Iran is, in fact, losing a little
bit of ground in this regional battlefield?
And if so, why?
Why is that happening?
COONS: Well, I think you put them in the right
order.
They have failed to be more successful at
projecting force and engagement in Yemen.
They have failed to be as effective a troublemaker
as they intended to be with the Houthis in
Yemen, in large part because of the distraction,
the expense, the cost in lives and money of
their venture in Syria.
And they've chosen to prioritize bolstering
Assad by shouldering a great deal of the fighting
burden.
Assad was in a very different place in the
battlefield a year, year and a half ago.
And IRGC troops, Shia militias, Shia fighters
from the whole region, from as far as Afghanistan,
who had been equipped, trained, and deployed
into the Syrian conflict by the Iranians have
allowed-obviously with active Russian military
help-has allowed Assad to really push back,
regain a fair amount of ground, and end up
in a quite different place, where today Assad
can credibly be talking about retaking significant
swaths of Syria.
So I think their failure to play a decisive
role in Yemen is really because of their distraction
in both Iraq and Syria.
To your point, they're discovering that Iraq
is every bit as difficult and demanding a
swamp as we found it to be.
I wish for them all the joys of entanglement
and the cost that that can bring.
But it doesn't show any change in their basic
orientation.
They've got a significant body of research
scientists that they're not working on developing
a nuclear weapon, so they're working on developing
ballistic missiles.
I'm not happy about either of these projects.
And they have a dramatic shortfall in terms
of what they need to deliver in economic support
for Rouhani's administration to move forward,
and for them to do anything positive domestically.
They're pouring a fair amount of the money
they're getting into fixing things domestically,
but the trajectory of their ballistic missile
program shows, I think, a continued hostile
intent and a continued desire to play bigger
role as a security threat to the region.
And I just view this was a temporary challenge,
because of the price of oil, because of the
difficulty accessing global markets, because
they haven't had the trajectory they hoped
for economically.
But they are making clear signs-they are demonstrating
that they have no less intent of spreading
a revolutionary message in the region and
of continuing to be a real hostile, difficult
force in the region.
IGNATIUS: Just to follow up on that, and then
go to the-to the audience.
It was a common line in criticizing the agreement
that freeing up these Iranian assets that
were frozen and allowing revenue to come back
into Iran would simply allow Iran to fund
its adventurism in the region more.
It was sort of like, well, the IRGC will get
more money to destabilize the region.
Do you see any-from what you just said about
where the money is going, it doesn't sound
like that's, in fact, happening.
But I wanted to ask you that directly.
COONS: A couple things.
Several of the presidential candidates in
the other party have repeatedly misstated
a basic fact.
Those frozen assets were not U.S. taxpayer
dollars.
And I found that profoundly irritating, the
frequency with which folks who know better,
who have been in the briefings, would say
billions of U.S. dollars are going to go to
Iran.
That was never the case.
These are billions of dollars that were frozen
in accounts around the world, in part through
American leadership.
There were significant disagreements about
how much the Iranians might ever get access
to, and how quickly, and from what holdings.
They have received far less than they had
hoped.
It is taking much longer than they had expected.
Secretary Lew and others have addressed that
dynamic in public remarks.
I'm going to be cautious in how much more
I say.
But I do think that has been an unexpected
dynamic for the Iranians.
It has been much harder for them to access
their frozen assets around the world than
they had expected.
But terrorism is cheap.
Frankly, the difference between whether they
got $1, $3, $10 or $50 billion is mostly going
to determine how much they have available
to invest in restoring the infrastructure
and the economy within Iran.
The terrorist actions that they have historically
supported are not that expensive, and they
continue to support them.
Obviously, they've continued to prioritize
funding their war efforts in Yemen, in Syria,
in Iraq, over restoring basic services to
their people.
What I am very pleasantly surprised with is
they haven't significantly increased that.
I think that's partly because of American
efforts to interdict weapon shipments, to
sanction entities, to keep our allies engaged
in pushing back.
And it's partly a choice by the Iranian regime
to pursue economic improvements domestically
and to focus on the conflict in Syria and
Iraq at the level that they can sustain, rather
than making it a higher priority.
IGNATIUS: That's helpful.
This image of a windfall for terrorism is
not supported by the facts.
COONS: Not so far.
IGNATIUS: OK.
Yes, please.
And please identify yourselves and, yes.
Q: Thanks, David.
I'm Barbara Slavin.
I run a program on Iran at the Atlantic Council.
Senator, I wanted to ask a couple questions.
Do you see any responsibility on the part
of the Saudis for the increase in fighting
that's been going on in the region?
You spoke of Iran as trying to export its
revolution, but in fact it's trying to shore
up a dictatorial regime in Syria.
That's not very revolutionary, in my view.
What do you think of the Boeing deal?
Is that good?
Is that something we should encourage?
Should Congress try to block it?
And finally, how do we institutionalize the
contacts that we have with the Iranians through
the JCPOA?
Should there be an effort to try to send Americans
to staff an intersection?
Should there be some way of doing more than
having occasional meetings in Vienna?
Thanks.
COONS: Those are three great questions.
Let me work through them backwards, if I might.
The importance of the personal relationships
that both Secretary Moniz and Secretary Kerry
enjoyed, you know, with Rouhani and Zarif
and Salehi, have been central, I think, to
the effective implementation of the deal so
far.
If Secretary Moniz is made aware of a technical
issue that pushes the boundaries or the definitions
or challenges some of the operation of this
deal, he's able to pick up the phone and directly
speak to someone he's known for decades, and
where they are both highly technically competent
themselves.
They are not relying on, you know, some series
of staffers to get them up to speed on exactly
how a centrifuge works and exactly what a
rotary means, and so forth.
We have to sustain that.
We have to invest, to your point about how
important are the institutional relationships.
Whoever the next president is, whoever the
next secretary of state and secretary of energy
is, assuming that they have the wisdom to
try and sustain the JCPOA, I think they have
to invest in those direct relationships and
those direct channels communication.
And I think that is going to be critical.
I am pleased that Ambassador Mull has a competent
multiagency team that is deeply experienced
and is staying on this.
And I think we have to sustain that as well.
I also think it's important to sustain congressional
familiarity with the technical details and
engagement, a better, broader understanding
of the region.
Look, I've only been to Saudi Arabia once
myself, to Turkey once, I've never been to
Iran-surprise.
I do think that making sure that members of
Congress, both houses, both parties, know
the context, know the region, are engaged,
is also going to be critically important.
I don't know what to say about the Boeing
deal.
Their argument is, where Airbus goes, we go.
Why would we deny opportunity to American
workers and machinists to be able to manufacture
and sell world-class airline-air frames?
And it is specifically called out in the JCPOA
as a specific market segment that we're to
try and participate in.
I leave it to Boeing to assess the risk to
them, whether or not the Iranians really are
credit worthy, whether or not this is an economic
engagement they really want to get more closely
involved in.
But it is a sign of American economic interest
moving up a step.
And I think it is a sign to the Iranians that
it is potentially possible to do business
with one of America's premier manufacturing
companies.
It's also a reminder that countries around
the world, even rogue states like Iran, prefer
American products and services, which I'll
just say with a small boosterism smile on
my face.
But I do think it-
IGNATIUS: What about Barbara's question about
a U.S. intersection?
COONS: My hope is that that's something we
could move towards.
Their behavior is among the worst in the world
when it comes to their treatment of-number
of executions, and treatment of journalists,
detention of Americans, and failure to account
for Americans who we know have disappeared
into their custody.
Look, we've recently reopened relations with
Cuba, in a robust way, for the first time
in decades.
If we can move in a positive direction that
sustains those open channels of communication,
I think that's well worth doing.
Q: (Off mic.)
COONS: You know, that's a complex relationship
that's become more urgent, I think, on both
sides.
There is new leadership in the kingdom.
And I'm hoping that there will be a real reexamination
of our long and close alliance.
I think the challenges-the security challenges
that they faced in Yemen has renewed a focus
on the competency and the engagement of their
military at all levels.
I think they've seen the United States come
to their support in a prompt and thorough
and meaningful way in the conflict in Yemen.
I think that has reassured them that we are
their allies, and we intend to work closely
with them and stand by them.
But there is an enduring question about their
role and their relationship with elements
within the Muslim world that have preached
a version of Islam that may have led, in some
parts of the world, to some more extreme views
and some more aggressive actions.
That's a delicate conversation and a difficult
one to have, but an important one to continue
having between friends.
IGNATIUS: The gentleman here.
Yes, please.
Q: As you well know, most of the region's
critics of the agreement are indifferent to
its details and to even the efficacy of the
agreement.
They put it in the context of a United States
that providentially shows up.
When Iran is in trouble with Saddam, the Americans
end up destroying Saddam.
When the Taliban are on the verge of war with
Iran, the Americans come in and destroy the
narrative.
There is this narrative.
Of course, it construes much more to these
events than they really carry.
But in that context, I believe that the evaluation
of the agreement is much influenced by our
current behavior in responding to the Iranian
provocation that you presented.
Even the little boat episode, which is here
forgotten-the boat episode was played up hugely
on the media.
There, they showed the American woman sailor,
officer, being forced to wear, they repeated
these scenes of humiliation.
And no American response.
The Americans don't respond.
Then there is, of course, on the ballistic
missiles, and you-well, again, you very carefully
observed there was no American response to
that, even though it appeared to be a very
deliberate provocation because of the proximity
in date to the signature to the launch and
so on.
Finally, even in countries whose human rights
situation is appalling, they do keep saying
the Americans make no effort to advance human
rights or to do-the typical American things
when America wants to interfere in a country's
internal arrangement the Americans don't do
in Iran, and some people connect it to the
failure to even mention the Green Revolution
on the part of the White House.
And as you know, there's a whole polemic with
that.
So I believe that, going forward, the actual-
IGNATIUS: Let's get this as a question-
Q: That is the question.
Do you believe that, going forward, it is
possible to uphold, as it were, the validity
of the agreement by changing the tone of U.S.
responses to Iran, or whether that would cause
the unraveling of the agreement?
Because you-
COONS: Yes.
Q: That is the answer?
That you-
COONS: I'm sorry.
I do think-you pointed to a very wide range
of conspiracy theories, incidents of provocation-let
me try to answer.
You've pointed to a whole series of conspiracy
theories, incidents that happened without
aggressive response from the United States,
and then other episodes that have gotten a
response from the United States, and then
some of the ongoing challenges, the tension
between our putting human rights at the top
of our agenda or putting security at the top
of our agenda.
That's a very broad range of topics.
Briefly put, I do think we have to be measured
in our response to provocations by Iran, but
I think we have to be firm and prompt and
act in concert with our allies.
I may disagree or quibble over specific incidents
and how the administration responded and why.
I may not have full information about what
the factors were they were weighing at the
time.
All I know is that going forward I think the
next administration has to place the effective
implementation and enforcement of this deal
high on their list of priorities at a time
when it's going to be hard to do that.
There's lots of other distractions in the
world, whether it's North Korea or Russia,
whether it's the South China Sea or the status
of NATO, there's a lot of other things we
can and should be worrying about.
But we can't ignore the ways in which this
deal and our relationship with Iran influence
and centrally effect the outcome in Syria
and Iraq, influence and centrally affect our
relationship with Russia, influence and centrally
affect the strength and importance of NATO
and the EU.
These are all tied together.
My concern, centrally-the point of my remarks
today-is a concern that this will drop from
view, as it largely has in the debates of
this presidential campaign.
My view is that it has to be higher in priority
and we have to be consistent in how we respond,
whether to provocations or to developments
in the region.
IGNATIUS: So I'm going to recognize people
in the order in which I've seen them.
The woman here at the front table, and then
you, sir.
Q: Louise Shelley, George Mason University.
You haven't talked about Turkey.
And I just came back from weeks in Turkey
where everybody is talking about the case
of Reza, who helped move millions or billions
of Iranian money through Turkey.
And Turks are still concerned, either positively
or negatively, that either that they should
be helping their neighbor Iran in the time
of economic difficulties and provide them
access to the financial system, or rather
that this is fostering corruption in Turkey.
And how do you perceive this issue of Turkey
being-you know, having facilitated so much
of Iran's money movements, as Turkey is a
NATO member and an ally of ours?
COONS: Well, our relationship with Turkey
is complex, difficult, and also an urgent
priority.
Our differences over how to respond to ISIS
and Assad, our differences in how we view
the Peshmerga, the Kurdish question have been
a source of real tension and challenge.
And how they're responding to security challenges,
how they're continuing to develop their democracy,
and some of the challenges within the governing
party, I think are all sources of legitimate
concern in the United States.
We need and want a closer, stronger, more
reliable partnership with Turkey.
I don't know enough about the details of how
money was moved, how much money was moved,
and what the corruption consequences might
be or the security considerations might be.
But we're going to face comparable challenges
with countries all around Iran, as the Iranians
seek more and more avenues to access the global
markets.
There are billions of dollars that are or
will be moving that have been frozen in banks
or that are waiting to reach the global markets.
And we still have sanctions on the books.
And we are going to continue to enforce those
sanctions.
And that means there will be unexpected and
perhaps unwelcome pathways of leakage in and
out of the Iranian economy.
So I simply point to this-thank you for raising
it-and I'll point to it as just another source
of playing in the joints or strain on our
vital regional alliances.
My hope is that we don't overemphasize it
in a relationship with Turkey where we have
so many other issues going on that are short
term, pressing, and tactically vital.
IGNATIUS: Mr. Cunningham.
Q: Thank you.
Nelson Cunningham, McLarty Associates.
First of all, I'm sure everyone comes away
from this wishing that every actor in our
political space brought as much intellect
and, frankly, painstaking care as you bring
to an important issue like this one.
In the course of the last several months I
spent an hour and a half with President Rouhani,
along with a group of American business people.
And in February, a similar amount of time
with Foreign Minister Zarif.
You've made it clear that from your perspective
this is a transactional-a transaction not
a transformation.
I took from their comments that they believe
this is potentially transformational.
And in fact, Rouhani and Zarif both made fairly
impassioned pleas to the members of the European
and the American business community to help
give them the economic benefits that they
believe they had promised the Iranian people
so that they could achieve their wish of making
this transformational.
But it's also plain that within the Iranian
government there are those who have different
views.
Rouhani and Zarif do not control the entire
government.
The Revolutionary Guard, as you pointed out,
takes a very different perspective.
To re-ask a question that David Ignatius asked
before, isn't there the possibility that by
helping to bring more commercial engagement
from the U.S. we could, indeed, be helping
an important internal conversation in Iran
between those like Rouhani and Zarif, who
perhaps share our values more, against those
within the government who do not?
COONS: I think there is that possibility,
yes.
And I think, as I tried to say before but
perhaps was unartful in how I conveyed it,
I think we have to remain hopeful, optimistic,
open to the possibility of the Iranian regime
reforming and changing, and to the possibility
that economic liberalization and opening to
the West will lead to that.
We are an optimistic people.
And we have to conduct foreign policy with
a priority on hope, informed by a clear-eyed,
skeptical, deep distrust of a regime whose
current actions demonstrate not just a disinterest
in rejoining the world community, but an active
disregard for it.
Now, obviously, it's not a monolithic regime.
There are internal tensions.
There are elements within the regime that
may be carrying out things like capturing
American sailors, or launching ballistic missiles,
or refusing to share internally what they
know about an American who's been missing
for years that's in their custody.
I recognize that, you know, there is no more
a unitary monolithic government within Iran
than there is within the United States.
But we have to be clear-eyed about their current
behavior, their past behavior, and its likely
trajectory.
I do think that-many of my colleagues have
met with Rouhani and Zarif and come back and
reported glowing things about their intentions
and their values and their priorities.
And all of that is good.
But I'm simply trying to push back on an optimism
that is not yet justified by actions.
In terms of the transaction of freezing their
progress towards enough fissile material for
a weapon, this agreement has been a success
so far.
But as an avenue towards transformation, I
think it will only be successful if we continue
to insist on the transaction being successful
first.
IGNATIUS: So the gentleman all the way in
the back with-yes-his hand raised.
Yes, sir.
Q: I'm Haik Gugarats with Argus Media.
Senator, is there room for one more transactional
agreement?
And what could Iran be asked to give up in
such an agreement?
COONS: Interesting.
There's a number of things that are much smaller
in scope than the nuclear program, but that
I think are of real significance in priority.
A ballistic missile program that is demonstrating
a greater and greater sophistication and capability
of delivering a nuclear weapon, should they
ever return to a nuclear weapons program.
Domestic enrichment capacity, which I understand
the dynamic between sovereignty and being
respected as a country with engineering capabilities
and so forth.
But I really question the legitimacy of an
expressed need for an industrial-scale nuclear
enrichment program.
There has been a fair amount of quibbling
about was this a good deal, a weak deal, a
terrible deal.
Those who criticize the deal at its simplest
level say: They're allowed to retain a domestic
enrichment capability.
There is no need for that.
They could continue to have nuclear reactors
to do research, to do nuclear medicine, but
have no enrichment and processing capability
within the country.
Some would argue that the IAEA inspections
and the restrictions of the JCPOA largely
deal with that, but I am concerned.
I'm concerned about its path forward.
I'm concerned about its trajectory more than
10 years from now.
So if there were two things that, to me, would
be the lynchpins of a next-stage transactional
deal, it would be Iran being willing to give
up on the continued development of ballistic
missiles capable of delivering nuclear weapons
regionally, and to give up on an ongoing nuclear
enrichment capability.
There should be significant further opportunities,
further engagement with the economy and the
world community were they to do that.
But that would be the sort of stage two or
JCPOA 2.0.
IGNATIUS: That's a fascinating answer to a
fascinating question.
And I want to just ask, would you-let's imagine
that Secretary Clinton is in the White House
next January.
Would you urge her to consider a new round
of this engagement with Iran on key strategic
issues, the two you mentioned, as a follow
on?
COONS: I would.
IGNATIUS: Yes, at this second table, if you're
still on.
Yes.
Q: Thank you.
Amy Nelson with the Council on Foreign Relations.
I wanted to ask you about IAEA support and
capacity, given that 20 percent of its existing
resources are now devoted to the implementation
of the JCPOA.
And given the significant need-ongoing need
for safeguards and their implementation and
verification, it would seem the IAEA might
be on the course to a crisis.
What can and should the United States and
the international community do to ensure that
it doesn't reach a crisis point?
And second, I wanted to ask you about your
comments on disputes in the implementation
of the JCPOA.
Given that certain language in the deal was
negotiated to be deliberately vague-for example,
as safeguard technology evolves we need flexibility
in terms of how its implemented.
And if you can comment on this, to what extent
were the disputes that we've experienced so
far a function of either this vague language
or sort of technical obstacles to implementation?
COONS: Good questions.
On the second part of your question, I don't
think we've yet reached the point where some
of the linguistic challenges you're referring
to have yet become operational.
I think the boundary fights have been much
more simple.
But willful misunderstandings if fairly basic
points that are relatively easy to say you
say this, we say this, agreement says this,
do this, so far.
But I think as time goes on, there may be
more challenges that are closer to the dynamic
you describe, where there is the opportunity
for litigating boundaries.
If nothing else, the Iranians are spectacularly
persistent at arguing lots of points.
My concern is that we remain spectacularly
engaged and determined and persistent around
procurement channel questions and at elevating
and resolving in favor of not providing access
to more advanced technology, not providing
more room for a robust program.
I'm sorry, the first part of your question
was?
Q: Support for IAEA.
COONS: Support for IAEA, right.
Look, we are asking the IAEA to do the biggest,
broadest, toughest job it's ever done.
And as I pointed out to Amano, and many of
colleagues have, this is an existential moment
for them.
This is the task that they will either truly
succeed at, and reinforce their role as the
world's absolutely indisputable, necessary
atomic watchdog, or where they will miss the
reemergence and development of a clandestine
program, and the consequences would be significant,
but for their reputation and for global security.
I think we need to be demonstrating a long-term
commitment to robust funding.
And the IAEA being a member agency, an entity
whose budget is made up of contributions of
many member states, it's concerned about not
being overly funded by the United States,
overly dependent on American financial and
technical support.
And I respect that.
And so I think we need to be finding ways
to ensure that the voluntary contributions
of all member states rise in accordance with
the complexity and reach of the IAEA's mission,
which continues to be global in scope, where
Iran is not the only or most difficult country
it's trying to monitor, but where the deployment
of new cutting-edge, real-time enrichment
monitoring capabilities of new real-time monitoring
and remote-sensing capabilities really have
the possibility to show what the IAEA can
do in this century.
The United States should continue to increase
funding for our domestic research into those
technologies and capabilities.
And our national labs should continue to provide
the training and the support that makes cutting-edge
nuclear inspectors that are well-trained and
properly deployed possible.
But more than anything, we have to show that
we are a reliable funder, because if you are
looking at ramping up the number of inspectors
you can deploy by dozens or hundreds, you
don't just go on Monster.com and hire a bunch
of nuclear inspectors willing to go live,
you know, in the Middle East on long stints
at the drop of a hat.
This requires a sustained, long-term investment,
something for which I'm fighting in the Appropriations
Committee, and that I expect will enjoy bipartisan
support for a long time.
IGNATIUS: I'm going to recognize one more
hand, that's Ambassador Cutler.
But I want to note we've come to the end of
our time.
So, Walt, please, a 30-second question and,
Senator, a 35-second answer.
(Laughter.)
Q: Very quickly, and I return to the initial
question that Barbara posed, regarding support
for our friends, our partners in the Middle
East-here, I refer to the Gulf States particularly-who
obviously recognize that Iran poses a continuing
security threat, as you put it.
And we're being very supportive, I think.
And the Congress, I think, is being terribly
supportive, which is very good.
Largest military sales, I think, in the history
of our country to the Gulf States.
But what do you say to those partners of ours
who say, look, we should start planning our
own nuclear capabilities?
COONS: That is one of the greatest potential
risks of an unraveling of the JCPOA.
So thank you for reminding me for failing
to put on the agenda of things that would
go badly quickly if a next American president
were to walk away from the deal, or in a ham-fisted
way attempt to renegotiate it and fail.
The speed with which some of our Gulf allies
would move towards the acquisition of a nuclear
weapon or a development of a domestic enrichment
program I think would be truly unsettling
and could lead to a significant increase in
regional tensions and risks.
So our best move is to continue to reinforce
to regional partners and allies our commitment
to their security, our determination to provide
them with the conventional defense means they
need, and to make it clear to them that we
will be clear-eyed, persistent, engaged, enthusiastic
about enforcement of the JCPOA, and the containment
of any Iranian nuclear ambitions, to forestall
any belief on their part that they need to
have a fallback position and be prepared to
develop their own nuclear weapons.
The development of a nuclear contest between
Pakistan and India was one of the riskiest,
most destabilizing developments of the last
century.
The nuclearized Korean Peninsula is showing
us even today the very real threats to security
posed by North Korea.
To have a nuclear-armed Iran and then a nuclear-armed
Saudi Arabia, and a nuclear-armed Kuwait,
and a nuclear-armed Qatar would be disastrous,
and something we should work very hard to
prevent.
IGNATIUS: So, with apologies to those I couldn't
call on, I'm going to bring this to a close.
We'll invite Senator Coons to come back a
year from now, and we can look at two years
on.
(Laughter.)
Senator, just to echo what Nelson Cunningham
said, it's really a pleasure to have someone
join us here at the Council who is so knowledgeable
about his subject.
We've all learned a lot.
So thank you very much.
(Applause.)
(END)